hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new let's play of dead space - okay I
know a lot of people were asking me
about this one ah whoo writing cool
stuff going on here it's a very very
neat neural mapping of a main menu
anyway so what I'm going to do is
because dead space didn't challenge me
at all uh really now I know what
happened on dead space I'm gonna try to
do a harder difficulty whoo hardcore on
to her cool um ammo and health are very
scarce and enemies will brutalize I
doubt it for veteran debts placed
players and one health had less
plentiful and enemies are more deadly no
I think I did like medium or normal on
dead space one I want to actually make
this a challenge like seriously bring it
on I haven't played a game yet where
I've really been challenged and shown
off my skills so I'm gonna do zelich if
I could do hardcore at do hardcore but
apparently I can't but right now I'm
gonna do cell cuz I'm a badass ah Nicole
Brennan she's dead
don't tell me she's not dead I know she
dead
I like dead space once emotion for only
great things about that stage - so I've
imagined it assessment
I'm really good game
Isaac Rita hell are you coming oh god
sorry I did look at the time different
long
okay Isaac talks good you're right Isaac
the issue mer is a great ship I am so
lucky to be serving aboard her enjoy
outlast you know they're gonna
decommission her next year I think thank
you for what we're just pushing me to do
this alright if it weren't for you I
never would have made it this far you
made me stick with it I'll just remember
I'm giving you up for six months say you
can do this you know what we must be
getting at a range there's Maggie
hello buddy EarthGov Edgar's foster
Isaac Isaac you were drifting away for a
moment there mr. Clark if they're Clark
I believe you were telling me about your
nightmares that you've been has he's
pretty good about your dead girlfriend
what was her name he cold Nicole didn't
want to end like this
sorry different she wanted to see you
again from her model and that's just
once I loved you I always loved you yes
they called Brennan she was a senior
medical officer stationed aboard a
planet cracker class vessel nubra USG
Ishimura who is part of a mine
separation on Aegis 7
I understand communications went down
shortly after their arrival you were
part of the repair mission oh ho a
mission for which you volunteered in my
right yar what did you find aboard that
ship Isaac monsters or not and that
thing but mostly mom find aboard the
ship Isaac monsters I'm telling you did
you have contact with this marker
it made you see things did many things
you didn't want to see who spoke to me
what no matter how busy you don't look
so good
Oh Isaac okay Isaac
I'll make it home baby that was freaky
oh hello who are you
Isaac Isaac can you hear me uh yeah I
can Dana I found Isaac Clark repeat I
have him good job
be careful he's been out a long time I
haven't checked up on Kelly's mom we
gotta get you out of the straitjacket
where where am I hey I know you're
confused right now I can explain
everything but you have to trust me okay
I sensed you you're in terrible terrible
teaser
oh that makes sense huh hey you let him
go and that darn bat
oh oh damn okay that's normal
all right buddy Wow okay you think I
need to run
hot damn guy just holy still crap cap
got you're gonna die whoa hello
why goodbye oh okay yeah this is
oh not that way shadow behind me hahaha
no no not today not today not today oh
well he friggin a button I guess I that
was that was a lot like the beginning of
dead space one I guess I was supposed to
be a premonition self you know the whole
um the beginning of that where you're
running away from the monsters so cool
also it's really darkened also I got to
say the graphics are much better really
liked it yeah sunflowers a body part
well if they wanted to confuse me they
did a good job where am I now
cuz that's a displaced one you got in
too
escape show we're on the planet oh hello
hey buddies whoa what hey
okay all right then
let's say that you guys deserve that oh
I can actually see you guys ik hello
handsome
how you doing look so good right here
Hey ha ha oh that is pretty
that's attractive my key subject OOP
that doesn't look good
ah death dismemberment bad stuff ok why
are there monsters here they're like did
they bring the all they were all they
brought up the marker back from on that
planet we're on
observation okay grab a waypoint thing
hello
oh yeah it's kicked chairs around
lockout Yubel my eyes looking much
better today yes don't you know it hurts
still hurts
yes I'll schedule you for another
session tomorrow no no I don't think I'm
ready I don't think I can take another
session over there first thing tomorrow
now let's talk about what you saw today
come on Stross come here to help you
yeah sounds like it was by deep black
I'm going over symbols symbols whisper
to me and why did this emotional aspect
tell you come on strong and wide it was
just short just start but it put so much
thought in my head so it [ __ ] in my head
just a full room for anything I can't
remember what he looks like
like if the symbol Stross what did the
symbols tell you told me that it wasn't
my fault I didn't kill him they didn't I
didn't desert this [ __ ] good mr.
Shiraz markandstacy suggests his
medication of 30 milligrams and we'll
try another session first thing in the
morning okay
crazy subject is my own Stross session 1
5 8 right so far I don't know why there
was suddenly like monsters everywhere
now no monsters at all
look I serves I don't even know many
servers oh hello hey buddy how's it
going are you that doctor guy ah doctor
said we Halicki subjects need to be
eliminated terminate uh-huh we can both
get out of here
just just cut me out of this
straitjacket I was getting out of here
alive oddly I will
hey oh okay
yeah I kind of expected that to happen
there's no escaping for what I've done
what have you done bro got a little
blood on your ears your rig is red
uh-huh
it's red yeah it sounds back in a
flashlight in that wall Locker you
should grab now okay buddy whatever you
say finally remembered that you were a
dog ahead take it
okay that's I won't be needing it
anymore I could I'd look around nope
II oh look at that I press the point
it's a what there's a present
oh yeah cute oh and got a flashlight
well that's fancy I bought it we're all
gonna burn for what we did to you okay
oh come on
hey why is everyone kill themselves in
front of Isaac poor guy he's seen so
many suicides was rody
oh you can even see the blood on his
neck can you stomp bodies Oh yep you can
not the crap out of you yeah guy goodies
don't trust you
bodies turn into monsters I remember I
remember I trust no one nothing in the
know whoa hello [ __ ] five o'clock hello
miss Dana I'm the one trying to rescue
you
why what's going on yes spring from a
unique form of dementia Isaac something
you can trash it on inches-7 oh yeah
really how do you how do you know all
this about me
your dementia will kill you oh if you
can get here I can't reach you and get
you to safety
yeah please you trust you because I'm
not the one cheating thank you no one
shot at me yet wait so I got a
flashlight
not even a gun a flashlight and what
what good does a flashlight do me person
old B oh yeah the locator uh who are
there different things I can look here
look at that hey I can oh that's so
handy I would again that's nice Oh
that is that a wheelchair whoa what's
that wouldn't be dead space without a
whole lot of goop everywhere I know how
to aim gosh yeah I'm not a noob I'm
playing on zealot mode was that
okay back okay
down normal house no here monster hair
monster [ __ ]
why are why are all these guys oh these
okay that's up there these are all the
subjects that the doctor was supposed to
kill what's that
that's a sack Oh
Audio log I got a person Captain Planet
Lee TPS report one four one eight the
recent realization that the popsicle
sticks were being constructed into
marker like miniatures for over a year
has led to a search of the unit for any
other such phenomena here's widespread
with marker forms being made out of
medication bottles hypodermic needles
and even toiletry items like nail
clippers and tweezers huh the research
teams have all been notified of the
discovery okay that's that's that's
plenty weird okay
I just spotted Savior Omar so creepy I
would say what uh some part of me wishes
that they didn't have that explosive
beginning because kind of like I kind of
like this right here it's ramping up to
the the atmosphere
like this like this I ran out of time
I'm gonna have to cut this episode here
but I am liking what I see so far the
graphics looked great the gameplay looks
familiar and the mouse isn't stupid i
noticing mouse is not stupid like it
were the last time so thank you all so
much for watching hope you enjoyed so
far and I will see you in the next part
bye bye